[Musique]
bien lu sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire on va retrouver dans cette
émission l'écrivain denis tillinac qui
vient hélas de nous quitter il était
dans cette émission en mars dernier pour
son dictionnaire amoureux du général de
gaulle je reçois également nicolas finez
pour love me please la biographie en
bande dessinée qu'il consacre à janis
joplin et le groupe grand palladium qui
sort son premier album et sera en
concert aux trois baudets à paris le 3
octobre mais commençons tout de suite
par notre époque qu'est ce qui
caractérise ce début de xxième siècle à
part les masques deux invités répondront
image alors voici la réponse de grand
palladium l'un comme l'autre un kevin et
vincent vous avez choisi la lame et
l'image qui va apparaître dans mon dos
de quoi s'agit-il exactement
c'est une boule de cristal
on s'est demandé un petit peu ce qu'on
pouvait trouver comme image qui
représentait ce début de siècle est une
hypocrisie certaine que ce soit dans nos
vies quotidiennes
ce soit politiquement écologiquement
on a beaucoup de mal à se projeter là et
avoir le christ est ça nous paraissait
être le bo qu'est ce qui nous arrive à
tout cela et vous regarder souvent
dedans mais je pense que c'est un peu la
technologie moderne c'est un peu ça
aussi j'ai l'impression c'est que tout
le monde et c'est à peu de regarder dans
une boule de cristal et c'est de savoir
ce qui va se passer c'est c'est un peu
c'est un peu ce qu'on essaie de faire
tous les jours je pense qu'on courait
ont fait partie des gens qui essayent de
regarder dans la boule de cristal
régulièrement alors nicolas finez lui a
choisi deux images la première
la voici c'est là la couverture de
charlie hebdo c'est un peu une image
d'actualité mais ça s'est presque imposé
j'avais dire avec hélas de les moments
tragiques qu'on vient de vivre et
revivre
moi je les choisis aussi parce qu'il se
trouve que j'ai connu une partie des
gens qui sont morts en 2015
avec l'attak de charlie je croisais cabu
et wolinski et tignes où ça a été il ya
longtemps l'un de mes proches vous avez
une deuxième image c'est une couverture
du deuxième stade est sain plus
exactement de rolling stones la
couverture de rolling ce que en 2017 une
couverture de rolling stones qui est que
j'ai trouvée extraordinaire parce que en
un dessin le l'auteur de ceux de ce
dessin attrapé tout ce qui fait le titre
ii de ce magazine à cette époque qui est
la folie de donald trump et j'ai pas
besoin de vous faire un dessin pour dire
à quel point on y est encore et comment
et notre quatrième a vite et c'est denis
tillinac qui vient donc de disparaître
il était dans cette émission mois de
mars dernier et à la même question
qu'est ce qui caractérise notre époque
voici sa réponse dutil inac votre votre
image à vous très récente 1 c'est
d'ailleurs oui je veux c'est ce matin
sur les écrans je trouve que c'est une
excellente symbolique de l'inexistence
politique de cette union européenne soit
disant 28 mai chacun dans son coin mais
là il faut voir arriver des conférences
ils sont chacun ça c est ça traduit
aussi les moeurs du privé ont fait
beaucoup de conférence à l'e3 les grands
magnats et puis en même temps c'est un
peu anxiogène dams et 28 chefs d'état
qu'il laisse entendre qu'ils peuvent
quand même pas foutu de risque minimum
de se retrouver entre eux est-ce que ça
n'aille pas à cause du corps réalisée
bien sûr oui mais exister qu'en avril
on doit protéger un peuple mais on ne
doit pas le doit pas l'angoissé
ils sont en train de la folle et enfin
c'est surtout cette solitude quoi chacun
pour soi est d'ailleurs chacun chaque
pays concerné prend des souverainement
la slovaquie la slovaquie ce matin
l'italie heures les mesures les mesures
qu'ils croient devoir prendre
et puis c'est très bien comme ça mais
bon pourquoi nous raconte l'histoire de
l'union européenne
ça fait plus rêver personne de james
bond
chapelon sur les travaux blofeld mais
c'était bien commençons
[Musique]
denis tillinac vous publiez dictionnaire
amoureux du général chez plon vous avez
écrit on va le voir sur la couverture du
général tout court
il ya même pas besoin de mettre son nom
c'est pas le le grand homme d'état qui
vous intéresse et le héros vous pas ce
qui m'intéresse c'est la façon dont un
chef qui est chef de guerre chef tout
court sécrète amis et que ce mythe
héroïque puisse survivre à tout ce qui
m'intéresse c'est comment il la juge
comment il a éclos et l'accueil le 17
juin 40
quand un officier supérieur normalement
ambitieux entrant gouvernement par la
petite porte et est vrai décide de
devenir un aventurier de rompre avec
tout n'était se rétablit terre sous
secrétaires d'état la guerre du
gouvernement paul reynaud à la défense
du gouvernement
tout d'un coup il devient un aventurier
mais il ya des aventuriers sont congelés
condottiere c'est le moi qui s'exalte
lui c'est un aventurier avec indécence
et la france alors une france idéalisée
il l'a défini dans les mémoires de
guerre comme
madone et princesses madone c'est la
pureté c'est la vierge princesse c'est
la noblesse
donc c'est ça france et à cette france
il va il va se vouer et le mythe de
devient héroïque de façon définitive
parce que pour avaler les circonstances
et le cadre arrive le tragique et le
tragique c'est là c'est la débandade du
gouvernement au long du mois de juin
jusqu'à jusqu'à ce que parce que raynaud
fils les clés du de plus grand-chose à
pétain et
il faut aussi gagner vaincre vin qu'il
faut que ce soit seul contre tous le
héros il est le héros il l'affronté
c'est comme dans les romans de latin
mais c'est de la table ronde 1 le
chevalier il affronte des épreuves
et puis les surmonter à la fin mais pour
moi c'est le 26 août 44
lorsque de gaulle descend les champs
elysées ac leclerc koenig ses compagnes
en allemagne pas les skis et d'autres et
qu'il entonne un magnificat notre dame
parce que ce soit voilà et la république
devient totalement légitime il l'a fait
adouber par les capétiens et par les
bonaparte parce qu'elle était très
contesté la république on peut dire que
tout le 19e siècle qui en conflit de
légitimité dans ce pays depuis
l'exécution louis xiii louis s'est
excusé bon ben là c'est fini c'est réglé
et donc le mythe devient indestructible
il va résister à la je vais résister aux
échecs qu'il en a connu beaucoup il peut
y avoir un parallèle avec napoléon spa
hasard si l'excellente historiens
gueniffey a publié un livre à succès il
ya deux ou trois ans que napoléon de
gaulle de héros français donc c'est
cette théorie héroïsme l'asl a même
survécu à la tambouille politique dans
laquelle justement au long des années 50
il a cru devoir se mêler n'est ce pas en
fondant le rpf donc c'était un parti
partis anti-système est parti un parti
quand même on ne fait pas quand on est
de golbey n'y est pas arrivé il n'y est
pas arrivé je n'ai pas arriver même
soleil est plus très lucide il était
agressif il était à côté de ses pompes
quoi il était pas été pas fait pour ça
c'est un chef tout court pas ne s'était
plus un homme politique alors votre
dictionnaire commence par acdi c'est
accès de mélancolie dont l'existence de
du général de gaulle a été jalonné la
première épreuve dite vous ce sont ces
deux ans qu'ils passent prisonnier en
allemagne pendant la première guerre
mondiale
cinq tentatives d'évasion cinq échecs
dans cette série le post la guerre il va
retrouver en 18 après
après l'armistice des camarades de promo
qui auront été plus glorieux que lui
s'est battue vaillamment il s'est
allongé il a été prisonnier s'évade et
il dit le seul l'honneur d'un prisonnier
ce n'essayez foutent le camp ça pas
manger il donne des conférences il à
bouquiner beaucoup et c'est beaucoup
moins m'enfin c'est année c'est un échec
terrible disais je sais plus pourquoi il
était sur terre 5 à 15 ans il avait
écrit quand même une petite saynète une
pièce de théâtre ou un certain général
de gaulle à la tête de l'armée française
battez l'armée allemande est sauvé la
france le deuxième
l'échec du débarquement à dakar en
septembre 40
un épisode pour être totalement oublié
des lions sont dramatiques passer des
français qu'on tirait contre d'autres
français des morts donc des français
loyalistes entre guillemets enfin en
tout cas obéissant au pouvoir de fait de
vichy depuis de gaulle à débarquer pour
commencer à construire
l'armé de la seule la frange de l'armée
de la france libre à partir de dakar
le débarquement échoue
et on entend même dire l'amiral
d'argenlieu que le goal a pensé au
suicide
c'est d'ailleurs lieu qu'il a dit a pu y
penser on l'a dit plusieurs fois qu'il
ya passé aussi en en 1 43 en mai 43 sous
l'injonction de roosevelt churchill lui
coupe les vivres
c'est le troisième moment j'essaie de le
neutraliser alors là bas on dit qu'il ya
eu un moment de déprime puis il y avait
de quoi
car des échecs après il ya un train
chargé du désert janvier 1 46 sont des
flancs tizi hibel france et fedex
il reconstruit pays actuellement
provisoire avec des réformes
considérables et les allocs le droit de
vote aux femmes
les comités d'entreprise puis voulait
aller plus loin il était très marquée
par un catholicisme social sur le plan
économique social et j'allais dire très
à gauche très beaucoup plus que son
entourage d'ailleurs ils y arrivent eux
pour savoir gouverner donc plus les
institutions de la troisième république
il échoue avant de convaincre les
français et il fout le camp avec une
quatrième république qui ressemble à la
troisième personne république est très
loin de la cinquième de ses voeux ne
savait alors il revient à ses vingt ans
après dumas c'est formidable s'est de
fait le retour parce que tous les
français
beaucoup de gens les mégots lycée une
confrérie retour d entre nous le général
et le le prolo lui espère que de gaulle
va mater les magnats les riches de
l'entrepreneur qui va calmer la cgt le
logiciel d'actifs qui va garder
l'algérie mais le
glatch et moi j'ai vu qu'un fils
militaire dans le contingent de forces
qui va mettre fin à cette guerre de
venir il nous renvoyait les gav est
vivant c'est possible personne ne veut
de gaulle pour la même raison mais on
veut d'eux en veut de gaulle de toute
façon et puis mairie curieusement il
revient mais à la fin 69 dernier échec
et 7 sera légitimée en avril 69 avec un
référendum qu'ils n'étaient pas obligés
de faire surtout n'était pas obligé de
mettre en jeu sa position de chef de
l'état pour lui ça va de soi et il est
désavoué il doit s'en aller d'ailleurs
depuis mai 68 ans il ya quelque chose
qui s'est déconnecté génération lui
disent ils voudraient du bonheur pour
des vols d'essai de la vigerie un jour
lisible bonheur vous aidera le bonheur
de l'acier mais vous êtes fous le
bonheur ça n'existe pas donc il n'y
avait plus rien à faire a qu'une
génération puisse aller jusqu'à 6 assez
égaux ça aussi c'est le propre du héros
il a multiplié les départs dans un pays
comme le nôtre où les politiques ne
partent jamais faut bien voir que
l'effondrement vérisme pas mais on les
retrouve tous dedans et puis par alors
le 17 juin 40 nous l'avait dit il au
moment où il était au gouvernement
ils sont là janvier 46 en janvier 46
alors il est libéré la france il s'en va
parce que la constitution qu'on vient de
voter lui plaisent pas parce que les
parties vont se retrouver au pouvoir
alors omar daf et puis aujourd'hui le 27
avril 69
il s'en va et c'est quand même
extraordinaire ça c'est barry dur parce
que ça vaut rien dire je souhaite
exercer mes fonctions cette décision
prend effet aujourd'hui à midi bref on
attendra plus j'avais la voix du jura ce
n'est pas un président de la république
on voit que le diable au salon du livre
comme les nôtres depuis viré depuis
sarkozy est revenu quasiment à tout de
suite s'est fait élire conseiller le
verbe resté un peu rare et solennelle
encore soulisse car mitterrand et chirac
c'est à partir de sarko pour des raisons
qui lui appartiennent
il a cru devoir désacraliser l'art in
selon gêne au lendemain du plus jeune on
va pas
conquis en conscience je crois de la
nécessité de restaurer de l'art
sacraliser un petit peu bas on sent qu à
la fois l'air du temps puis les
maquereaux et difficile l'an n'empêche
ils essayent et elle a par moments ce
qu'avec l'accord du en commun c'est
d'être heureux papa faut jamais faire ce
que pendant un grand homme politique
andré 7 doit jamais faire ce que les
communicants lui 19e jamais de gaulle il
a quand même toujours deux ou trois
coups d'avancé constamment ce thème ces
véritables ce qu'on appelle un
visionnaire produits vais d'ailleurs dès
le 18 juin 40
dès le 18 juin 40 et on le voit dans son
discours il comprend que on est qu'au
tout début de la guerre que l'amérique
et la russie vont rentrer dans la guerre
est pas de la façon en arrivant à la
russie qu'on croit et je me suis rendu
je me suis toujours dit la haine que
mitterrand a toujours joué à de gaulle
je montre si elle vient pas de là
mitterrand lui n'a pas eu n'a pas eu la
lucidité il a cru à la victoire de
l'allemagne mitterrand quand il sent
quand il c'est vrai il arrive à vichy il
croque le terrain c'est un patriote
sincère qui est blanc comme de beaucoup
de sa génération que pensait que c'est
que c'était fini qu avec la france
n'avait plus dans tout ça c'est vraiment
ma patrie c'est la france mon avenir et
je pense que j'ai toujours voulu à 2 go
il n'a pas été plus lucide que lui n'a
bien sûr il n'a pas vu arriver la
réunification de l'allemagne il a pas vu
arriver l'implosion de l empire
soviétique
teddy c'est ce que de gaulle est le plus
visionnaire vous avez raison alors sur
le plan militaire elle dit ça sera une
guerre mondiale tôt ou tard les america
seront obligés d'intervenir
la mécanique gains mais aussi le voilà
chef de guerre mais lydie la france
c'est moi et le voilà chef tout court
donc il faut qu'il pense le monde pense
le monde d'après et des 41 effet une
conférence à oxford prêts étudiants
français à oxford nakheel une analyse ce
que va être la société de consommation
de massifier avec des imaginaires
normaliser les feuilles cia baudrillard
et les six classes et de bordes déjà
dans ce discours en 41 l'officier né en
la belle époque c'est prodigieux
en revanche il n'a pas compris la
jeunesse
quand mai soit son passage la romance
c'est vraiment ça lui l'a compris la
jeunesse de 1940 il aimera compris la
jeunesse de des années 60 qui au bout de
dix ans en avait marre de général c'est
pas ça le pauvre sûr que je démens
j'avais 20 ans je n'ai pas de jugement
un peu mieux il y avait
il y avait une problématique even les
revendre et parce que tout ce qui était
de l'ordre de la révolte contre les
autorités verticale l'armée la police
les curés les parents s'était un peu
fait dans les 50 ça me fait rigoler
quand j'entends souvent quelqu'un dany
cohn-bendit lui ont dit que ça a été une
espèce de l'effet recense de révolution
sexuelle cependant quelques dates des
boutonneux gauchos qui avaient attendu
mon 70 lisez jamal et les romans de
salon bonjour tristesse et 53 et dieu
créa la femme vadim avec bardot
sublimement à poil c'est 54 56
l'autorité de nos parents mais je vous
assure il a beaucoup décliné non tout ce
qu'on attendait c'était la pilule bon ça
c'est le may have enough les red bull
dudu l'appel il accepter l'image de vol
quand tu ne vis remis la santé vient de
lui dire il faut plus qu'il faudra
rembourser
on va me rembourser la bagatelle il
qu'il ait du mal bart dockx allemand
madame mais alors là mieux compris parce
qu'elle a su qu'il y avait des filles et
failles et des cadres d'abattement
lamentable pour les jean paul est si
pauvre n'avait pas les moyens d'aller
comme les bourgeois en angleterre
puisque et la facture aujourd'hui s'il
ya quelque chose d'héroïque chez le
général de gaulle est ce qui fait que
aujourd'hui alors qu'il a été vraiment
détesté hinglé toujours cette fois que
je fais comme chroniqueur ici ou là tu
sais tu veux
j'évoque la figure la mémoire de gaulle
d'une façon ou d'une autre c'est
toujours plus tôt louangeux jeu j'ai des
led d'un site non c'est toujours les
mêmes oui c'est tout ce qui l algérie s
est tout ce qu'il ya peta voilà c'est
quand même une minorité ou bien on a une
famille politique
69 quand il sort valley mais ce que je
veux dire c'est qu'aujourd'hui dans son
côté héroïque c'est la fameuse phrase de
françois fillon qui imagine le général
de gaulle mise en examen le revenu et je
roule à 2
oui parce qu'en plus il se trompe c'est
à dire que le général de gaulle
aujourd'hui serait mis en examen comme
tout le monde
à l'époque c'est quand même tout à fait
un autre monde mais de médiapart existe
pas le canard enchaîné
mais ne fait pas dans kate devrait pas
de journaliste d'investigation il ya le
rtf lui appartient quand il vient ici
les réponses à l'avance pourrait lui
poser
personne ne lui parle jamais de l'argent
de la françafrique des polices
parallèles personnes non mais ça c'est à
dire qu'on est dans une démocratie qu'on
qualifierait aujourd'hui d'autoritaire
rubrésus démocrature alors ce qui est
vrai c'est que je pense à la titre
personnel on pouvait pas il y avait rien
à dire vous pouvez investiguer autant
qu'on voulait sans doute d'une intégrité
bon nsany gens qui étaient autour de lui
il était pas moralement but valable que
ceux qui sont autour doté autour de
mitterrand à sarkozy de hollande ou le
maquereau le héros de celui qui tire les
gens vers le haut d'un type ordinaire
vous faites vous fait un compagnon de la
libération que s'il n'ya pas le aubin
vos rivaux mais des grives au potentiel
il y en a autant que des eaux vrai ce
que je vous dis ce que nous dira rivaux
et les magazines arrive dans une société
de jeux d'hier où les s de nos égos sont
tout ce qu'on nous promet la publ a
souhaité de consommer ce que je veux
dire c'était plus facile à l'époque
d'être d'être le général de gaulle il
l'avait dit lui même le prestige ne va
pas sans mystère car l'on révère peu ce
que l'on connaîtra le prestige est
encore à portée de la main
on vous filme pas avec un iphone vous
n'êtes pas interviewer partira garçon il
faut ou par yann barthès là parce que
j'ai un autre sa légitimité ne vient pas
des urnes elle vient de l'histoire de
l'histoire dans sa g n le midi le mythe
vient là de toute façon soit son
autorité était naturel j'ai encore quand
j'ai connu encore quelques-uns non quand
il était en face de vous le fais pas de
plan précis on n'a pas la chef d'état il
était en face d'un dédain fantômes qui
est porté par la mémoire longue de
l'histoire à ce passe-temps alors
effectivement bons délais
et scandales il y en a eu mais si vous
voulez commis sa veste se tenir retenue
il détestait auteurs les douves de la
ville c'est bien connu mais ils savaient
tous se tenir quand même davantage
et surtout il avait il avait décrit
d'aidé dans le fil de l'épée ce que doit
être un chef la parole vous l'avez dit
doit être
il doit surprendre la parole doit être
rare et solennel mais ils savent plus
tenir ils ceux des bombes
il passe par les politiques aujourd'hui
son lit sont les pentes pas alors c'est
un micro on ne peut pas on peut pas les
invités et ancrer encore quand c'est a
dit c'est pour dire des choses
intelligentes mais à plein temps c'est
pour dire des conneries il se démonétise
est ce qu'on doit faire autrement bien
sûr que oui les films et bien qu'il soit
portable est bien plus que jamais au
moment des on est en une époque de
réseaux sociaux et de et d'info en
continu un pour échapper à cette espèce
d'europe de l'est ces mères qui fait que
ces décès des kleenex on les utilise
ils les voilà notabilisé on les utilise
et puis on les jette
il devrait tout en plus manière surtout
les chefs 1 au sommet qu'ils essayaient
roulera remarquerez que et chaque
président essaye quand il est élu et à
chaque fois on lui dit qu'il est trop
loin des français il avait une bonne
image au début macron pendant l'e3
polémique ne fut que neil que ne l'at il
garder et puis dès qu'il est sorti dans
la rue on allons la filmer que les
téléphones portables au moment où il
disait qu'il voulait trouver du travail
elle est en phase de le connaître la rue
y en a ils nous disent autres et c'est
trop exposés on a là on va avoir encore
une confiant la vue 3,3 fois depuis ce
matin il le sait vu madame ndiaye ad
nous a dit qu'il y aura une conférence
du le président de la république demain
dire imaginez de gaulle avec les
coronavirus au fond et un truc c'est
sérieux quand même encore voxan
quand on convoque son premier ministre
et son ministre de la santé alors dit
bon vous allez vous occuper de ça
l'intrus qu il n'en parle même pas ce
n'était pas du niveau d'un chef d'état
oui mais parce que c'est pas le maire ya
eu un conseil de défense arrivé ailleurs
une quarantaine de morts parce qu'il ya
malheureusement des sur les dents comme
accidentés de la route tous les
week-ends il rayonne
délirant c'est des systèmes dénis
aujourd'hui le président de la
république est élu pour cinq ans comme
son assemblée nationale c'était donc
cesser de leur premier ministre
il fallait vous avez raison c'est une
autre chose sans les avantages du régime
présidentiel et puis il utilise pas le
premier ministre est fait pour être un
fusible il a un bon premier ministre
edward fini mais il n'est pas utilisé il
n'est pas utilisé matheron et toujours
il se met trop en bon état est libre
sommes de toute façon le il valait pas
adapté moi j'ai voté de contrôler la
pensée que général de gaulle tiendrait
aujourd'hui ma chère pression qu'au bout
de deux jours il serait impopulaire et
mis en examen
cette race est biaisé parce que
j'éprouve une certaine proximité
étrangement alors que j'ai là 38 ans la
trentaine mais j'ai été élevé par mes
grands parents par mon grand-père
notamment qui avait été résistant qui
était né en 1924 et donc qui m'a qui m'a
élevée en parlant beaucoup du général de
gaulle et pour moi enfin le seul
président que j'ai connu dans mon
enfance et mon adolescence et le général
c'est très paradoxal donc au milieu des
années 90 est gaulliste est assez
étrange mais et puis mon nom mon parrain
était son chef de sécurité lorsque à
l'étranger donc c'était quelque chose
d'assez présent je suis assez proche de
ce que dit denis ferrand et je suis
assez ému de l'aide d'écoutés j'ai pas
mousse et depuis tout à l'heure
parce que parce que ça à la fois beau et
à la fois je ne sais pas cette épreuve
de la réalité mais le réel d'aujourd'hui
qui serait étanche à ce qui se passe qui
serait temps choses à faire encore
aujourd'hui mais je crois que justement
lui et est équipé pour cela d'abord
parce qu'un certain recul avec un
certain goût pour la métaphysique ca
certain sens de la solitude culture
générale une culture et une écriture et
surtout alors on lui churchill de
l'autre côté de la manche pour cent son
humour et son esprit mais le général de
gaulle n'a rien à lui envier
pour la france moi je trouve que la
meilleure parce qu'il résume sa phrase
qui résume le plus l'esprit française et
comment voulez vous gouverner un pays
avec 250 variétés comme un joueur je
trouve que c'est tellement vrai et alors
aujourd'hui on a encore plus de vous
voyez que la france est définitive
décidé moi
tellement plaisir d'entendre quatre
carrés moi j c'est nettement plus jeune
que moi je dire ce que vous dites qu'on
peut dire denis tillinac sur mai 68 moi
je viens d'une famille mon père était
pilote de chasse de la première guerre
mondiale
ma mère était pieds noirs donc chez moi
de gaulle c'était le gros con la
brillante hockey ensuite de gaulle en 68
c'est quoi ses 1800 louette 18 ans et
une silhouette dessinée par signer donc
on fait tomber une silhouette en carton
on n'a pas vaincu le général de gaulle
on a vaincu cette société de nos parents
qui vivaient sous l'égide du péché de la
guerre mondiale parce que je pense que
tout le monde est sorti avec le poids de
la culpabilité de la guerre mondiale et
qui est donc il a suffi de faire et ça
me fait rien d'autre part les de tanis
parce que la photo de cohn bendit la
plus connue c'est ça il rigole avec un
intérêt sa faute car on voit là un peu
d'huile car de crs en face donc nous on
a fait ça et pouf c'est tombé le sexe
dans l'histoire ce que vous décrivez
c'est les gens plus âgés que nous qu un
permis baiser pour dire les choses très
clairement aux nouvelles c'était pas ça
c'est nous on a porté ce qui était libre
dans les milieux huppés dans le peuple
c'est à dire et ça c'est la pilule c'est
à dire le droit a au plaignant auprès
des mêmes et pour terminer on est dans
une époque où trump tweets et insultes
comment voulez vous que le général de
gaulle puissent exister dans une époque
comme ça général de gaulle avec ses
pouces sur le segment pousse sur un
petit clavier non c'est pas jouable
et pour finir moi je dirige un journal
qui s'appelait métal aventure le métal
hurlant et on avait fait une couverture
dans 80
3 et c'était une image de yves chaland
un dessinateur a présenté deux goals en
train d'égorger un soldat allemand avec
la photo et ça s'appelait de gaulle
seuls contre le reich et on vendait de
gaulle comme les aventuriers de l'arche
perdue et on avait fait un article
formidable sur de gaulle le héros et des
radeaux pour vous dire la trajectoire
voilà mais oui c'est sans doute la
dernière figure historique
les figures héroïques de l'histoire de
france oui c'est l'année en est c'est la
dernière en date
oui oui c'est ça je nous donne
l'occasion de faire émerger une nouvelle
fois moi je crois que vous avez vous
n'avez pas tort devrait se comporter de
façon différente mais je crois que le
message reste vrai alors donc la tenue
le 60e porteurs de d'une mémoire melon
ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure sur le 26
août 44 le l'inconscient politique
français c'est un trépied yahia
l'inconscient monarchie pas forcément le
régime et le regret de l'unité perdue ce
que macro à signaler dans une chronique
pendant la campagne présidentielle il ya
une triple républicaine très forte en
assurant elle remonte presque au premier
c'est le goût de l'égalité au premier
âge où les chrétiens
attendez la fin du monde est partie
partagée tout et puis à la grandeur
napoléonienne qui a généré tout le
romantisme français toute l'année je
suis venu trop tard dans un monde trop
vieux
on a mais on en est toujours là donc
c'est son message c'est qu'il faut c'est
dur d'être là d'avoir le cul ture attire
un trépied de me casser la gueule
il faut être à seaside deuxième message
ce qu'il avait dit un jour à palleschi
d'abord la france ensuite l'état après
le droit or maintenant il inverse tout
c'est pour ça qu'ils gouvernent mal et
ce n'est pas le genre sont pas contents
voilà c'était denis tillinac en mars
dernier il vient de nous quitter à l'âge
de 73 ans on se retrouve juste après une
pause avec nicolas fille mais pour
parler de janis joplin
[Musique]
interdit d'interdire continue avec
nicolas finez vous êtes journaliste
documentariste scénariste de bd de love
me please en particulier une biographie
de janis joplin décidé par christopher
qui paraît chez marras bull
pourquoi janis joplin pourquoi pas jimi
hendrix jim morrison
parce qu'il ya une latte ya un
cinquantenaire janis joplin est morte le
4 octobre 1970 donc dans quelques jours
cela fera exactement 50 ans et donc il y
avait une sorte de commémoration si on
peut dire alors cela dit elle est morte
je crois quatre jours après après jimi
hendrix et oui les quelques et quelques
semaines avant le jim morrison donc
j'imagine qu'il y aura je troque
commémoration pour eux
on découvre dans cet album qui est
chronologique qui est une vraie
biographie que c'est sur le campus de
l'université d'austin au texas qu'elle a
commencé à chanter et avoir un certain
succès en tant que chanteuse
on imagine pâte texane janis joplin un
vu la suite n'ont d'ailleurs elle a
hélas pendant toute une partie de sa vie
elle à cacher ses origines elle n'a pas
crié sur les toits qu'elle était qu'elle
était texane parce que justement dans la
californie de l'époque était beaucoup
plus libre de moeurs
il est beaucoup plus ouverte c'était pas
une image terrible de que de s'afficher
venant du texas
certes est d'ailleurs ça va pas ça s'est
pas très bien passé pour un au texas à
la fois avec sa mère était très
puritaine mais même avec ses camarades
d'université karama rade entre
guillemets puisqu'il pouvait pas la
supporter et vous raconter cette
anecdote qui reste est célèbre
elle a été élu l'homme le plus laid du
campus de l'université 1
c'est quelque chose par donkey kilkee là
qu'il a effectivement accompagné qu'il a
marqué au fer rouge pendant toute sa vie
ça a été terrible pour elle et il ya une
blessure laquelle à qu'elle a traîné
toute sa courte vie qui était vraiment
très très dur alors elle a un petit peu
chercher en fait elle est janis sa
nature est une grande gueule c'est
quelqu'un qui l'a ramenée donc à
l'université elle était envahissante
elle l'était elle avait besoin
terriblement d'où le titre qu'on a
choisi et christopher leurs milices très
besoin d'être aimé et elle le faisait
savoir très fort très souvent sans doute
de façon un peu insistante ou pénible
parfois et une partie de ses camarades
d'université qui est probablement
n'étaient pas les plus éveillés on pas
trouver autre chose pour se venger
d'elle que de les lire le mec le plus
moche du campus des sas et lads c'est la
déchirure qu'il qu'il a marqué pour
toujours et c'est ça qui l'a fait fuir à
san francisco d'après ce que ce que
raconte votre votre album san francisco
alors là c'est le flower power qui est
en train de naître
et là elle va avoir du succès tout de
suite hein alors en fait elle était allé
brièvement à los angeles et à san
francisco enfin 61 lave est ébloui
justement parlant d' par la liberté
qu'elle y avait trouvé quelqu'un qui ne
veut rien à voir avec ce que ce que ce
qu'on vivait alors au texas
et lorsque se produit cet événement qui
pour elle est très difficile d'être
d'être élu le type le plus moche du
campus effectivement l120 elle dit voilà
moi j'ai plus rien à faire ici et je
vais essayer de tenter ma chance dans
cet endroit merveilleux de la mairie qui
est le la californie est effectivement
comme c'est un endroit très ouvert elle
commence à chanter mais tout de suite ça
marche alors ça marche
à une échelle modeste 1 c'est pas tout
de suite le triomphe qu'elle connaîtra
plus tard
bien sûr elles sortent dans les bars
elle rencontre tout de suite l'alcool et
la drogue l'alcool elle connaissait déjà
mais la drogue elle s'enfonce très
rapidement et très elle va très très
loin elle
elle est quasiment clocharde assez
rapidement elle y va pas avec le dos de
la cuillère c'est le cas de le dire
parce qu'elle prend numéro en plus en
fait c'est un c'est une jouisseuse janis
joplin c'est quelqu'un qui a faim de
vivre qui a soif de vivre qui a des
relations difficiles avec une partie du
monde et donc elle l a terriblement
besoin de s'abandonner à ça et en plus
effectivement elle pratiquement aucune
inhibition aucun interdit donc ali va
joyeusement si on peut dire mais
effectivement un moment elle y fait
tellement fort que l sabine dans la
drogue elle et elle est bisexuelle en
plus donc effectivement est là elle n'a
aucun tabou
c'est en juin 66 que sa carrière
commence vraiment avec le groupe big
brother the holding company
pour vous c'est une chanteuse de kwh est
une chanteuse de blues janis joplin et
uniquement de blues on s'est tu as
tellement ou la case est aujourd'hui
est-ce que tu une chanteuse de rock de
folk
pour moi c'est vraiment une chanteuse de
rock mais elles puissent ses sources et
son inspiration d'une part dans le monde
du folk donc qu'elle a côtoyés au tout
début justement à l'époque de d'austin
dans vous parliez tout à l'heure qui
sépare laquelle a commencé et puis elle
est littéralement habité par les
musiques noires et sa salle influence
énormément mais moi je là il faut la
rangée je dirais que c'est tout de même
tout de même une chanteuse de rock
alors on le voit là sur ce sur le dessin
qui étiez là il ya la première la
pochette du premier album de big brother
and the holding company qui a paraît il
n'ya pas son nom sur la pochette elle
est vraiment la chanteuse du groupe 1 ce
mois là c'est pas janis joplin qu'un
super star comme on la connaîtra dans
quelques années non pas du tout elle a
fait une espèce de hold up en fait ce
groupe préexiste à son arrivée et puis
mais très vite donc elle se joint à eux
et très vite elle prend le pas sur tout
le groupe parce que là c'est de voix
absolument phénoménale donc le premier
album elle et sa présence est encore
discrète mais évidemment ça va changer
avec le second album dont la pochette
est dessinée comme chacun le sait par le
robert crumb et la salle est vraiment
l'explosion robert crumb seyfried ce
cadre c'est le grand dessinateur de
cette époque là aux états unis il ya une
date qui est très important dans la
carrière de jay joplin c'est le festival
de monterey stamm enterrait qu'elle
devient véritablement une star oui
absolument cesser alors c'est le premier
grand festival de cette époque
ça correspond très exactement et la
période du flower power et ce qui est
étonnant c'est qu'elle réussit là aussi
un espèce de coup de force qui est de
chanter deux fois en principe le groupe
est programmé une seule fois mais elle
n'a pas pu obtenir que le groupe soit
filmé la première fois et donc elle je
raconte passant le détail mais ça je le
raconte dans le livre elle fait une
espèce de manip est un espèce de hold up
à nouveau pour pouvoir être filmé donc
on a ces images
duy il et c'est phénoménal elle
impressionne tous ceux qui sont là je
crois que c'est à monterrey aussi que
les américains découvrent jimi hendrix
qui est qui qui s'est fait connaître à
londres et qui arrive à ce moment là
dans son pays natal où il va devenir lui
aussi une star elle doit elle devient
d'ailleurs la maîtresse de enfin la
maîtresse elle couche avec jimi hendrix
elle couche avec eric clapton elle
couche avec jim morrison elle couche
avec leonard cohen
qu'est-ce qui lui trouvaient tous
puisqu'elle avait été élu le garçon le
plus laid du du campus s'était pas non
plus par hasard c'était pas un premier
prix de beauté
janis joplin c'est très étonnant gelé
beaucoup côtoyé pendant que pendant que
l'on faisait ce livre est selon les
photos elle peut être repoussante ou
très très attirante elle est là vraiment
on sent que c'est très certainement
dépendant de ces états psychologiques
elle pouvait être très séduisante et je
pense que il ya une partie de ces hommes
et il y en a eu beaucoup
et de ces femmes il y en a eu beaucoup
aussi qu'ils se sont laissés attirer par
eux justement ce qu'elle pouvait avoir
de très accrocheur comment elle se
débarrasse de son groupe
parce que assez rapidement quand on vous
lit tout le monde lui dit que le groupe
ait pas la hauteur mais c'est pas facile
de se débarrasser d'un groupe surtout
d'un groupe qui existait alors elle qui
ne réalisent probablement pas qu'il
n'est pas à la hauteur de la chanteuse
s'est toujours problématique
et ça se fait pas comme ça elle se sert
de sa maison de disques sa maison de
disques la pousse dans ce sens là parce
que les patrons du label six billets ça
l'époque columbia on absolument compris
qu'ils avaient entre les mains et le
potentiel au sens commercial du terme
qu'il y avait là dedans et donc tout le
monde du côté de la maison dit cela
pousse à se séparer du groupe mais
évidemment elle a des scrupules parce
qu'elle est arrivée après et qu'encore
une fois elle a fait une sorte de hold
up sur ceux sur cette formation est en
fait elle s'en débarrasse l'espace d'une
journée en les congédiant un peu gêné
mais en essayant dé tout de même
relativement gentil si on peut dire il
ya un des musiciens qui reste avec
quelques belles âmes zhu qui va
l'accompagner dans ses autres groupes
elle devient à ce moment là janis joplin
tout court même si elle aura d'autres
groupes pour l'accompagner mais c'est
véritablement que j'avais déjà pris
c'est la star jopling et c'est la drogue
encore plus qu'avant
oui elle est là elle est hantée farce
par ses fantômes
c'est ce qu'on peut c'est ce qu'on peut
résumer ou par ses démons elle n'arrive
pas à s'en déprendre en plus celle là
elle est un peu velléitaire les ailes
sans doute qu'elle a une volonté assez
faible de ce point de vue là donc elle a
bien conscience je crois qu'elle est en
train de sombrer qu elle fait à l'aide
elle adopte des comportements qui lui
sont préjudiciables mai donc c'est très
puissant ce sont des addictions on sait
que les élections c'est pas facile de
s'en débarrasser et puis à cette époque
tout où la pousse au crime j'allais dire
donc effectivement c'est de mal en pis
alors tout ça ça se passe dans un très
court laps de temps elle a 23 ans quand
quand elle commence véritablement sa
carrière avec the big brother un holding
company elle en a 27 quand elle va
mourir
donc on voit bien que ce en très peu de
temps c'est 4 5 ans qu'elle va vivre à
plat l etat woodstock il fallait
absolument y être elle y est elle chante
à 2 heures du matin mais c'est
extraordinaire
oui absolument elle est là cet instinct
d'être d'être là où il faut et puis
effectivement ça va à une vitesse folle
alors il faut resituer ça aussi par
rapport à l'époque n'y a pas là à
l'époque l'immédiat sont pas aussi
puissants qu'ils le sont aujourd'hui
aussi instantané donc il ya des moments
clés comme ça elle ne les rate pas et
effectivement ça va à une vitesse
absolument phénoménale et en l'espace de
quatre disques seulement quatre années
elle réussi une carrière qui aliment
inouïe et alors elle à l a7
je sais pas comment le qualifier
d'ailleurs elle revient à port arthur
qui est son petit bled au texas
elle revient alors qu'elle est au sommet
de la gloire elle revient en fait faire
la faire là la niaque
ses camarades de lycée qui la détestais
qu'il a trouvée laide qui la trouvaient
trop marginale elle ne respecter aucune
convention elle revient faire également
des pieds de nez à sa famille au fond un
oui c'est un épisode qui est très triste
que moi je trouve très triste assez
pathétique et effectivement on a
l'impression qu'elle a besoin de prouver
à ceux qu'ils l'ont maltraité qu'ils
l'ont qui l'ont injurié qu'ils l'ont
qu'ils ont jetés qu'elle a besoin de
prouver aux crétins kelly est arrivé
malgré tout et il ya eu hier ça a été
filmé cette séquence donc on sait ce
qu'elle a dit ce qu'elle a fait et c'est
très triste parce qu'on voit qu'en fait
les gens qui sont là n'ont pas
grand-chose à faire dialyser houplines
mais ils sont obligés de les respecter
parce qu'elle a l'aura de l'artiste qui
a réussi et elle revient là elle et
c'est d'une certaine manière de se
racheter
elle essaie aussi sans vraiment y croire
de renouer avec une partie de sa famille
mais ça se passe pas très bien comme ça
ces jeunes jamais d'ailleurs très très
bien passé
sa famille est donc c'est un épisode
très court elle elle revient pour le un
anniversaire de son lycée ça dure une
journée et elle repart sans évidemment
si vous en avoir rien obtenu
et je trouve que c'est un épisode où
elle apparaît d'une grande fragilité
face et très touchant et deux mois après
elle est morte
oui c'est ce qu'on voit souvent dans les
films quand on revient pour le dixième
anniversaire de la promo ou poumon de se
revoir pour voir ce qu'ils ont réussi
ceux qui ont raté et on s'attend pas il
voir janis joplin et pourtant elles y
étaient elles revoient aussi jim
morrison
au moment où ou hendrix vient juste de
mourir à londres elle revoit morrison à
los angeles lui il part pour paris
il va mourir dans bon quelques semaines
également je crois et et puis elle elle
va mourir
quinze jours après hendrix
d'une overdose dans sa chambre d'hôtel
comme hendrix à londres et
là c'est le club des 27 1 à ce moment là
il commence à peine il ya eu brian jones
juste avant et puis s'est étendue depuis
ça pouvait buzz
on a l'impression qu'aucun d'entre eux
ne pouvaient dalena les survivre oui
c'est pour ça que j'ai traité ça sur ce
mode un peu crépusculaire parce que
effectivement il ya l'idée d'une espèce
de malédiction
personne ne réussit à se déprendre de
ceux de ce monde de l'addiction est
enfoncé jusqu'au cou et ils sont tous
condamnés d'une certaine manière est
effectivement voilà ça le sait le début
de ce club des vingt sept a en fait
qu'une invention médiatique à ussel et
bien ça
personne n'a jamais appeler ça comme ça
à cette époque mais bon comme il ya eu
d'autres morts plus tard kurt cobain amy
winehouse et d'autre on on a créé ce
cette appellation qui est séduisante
parce que effectivement ça réunit en une
formule tous ces gens qui sont mort en
pleine gloire
qu'est ce qui reste de janis joplin
aujourd'hui est ce qu'elle vaut toujours
autant de disques
je suis incapable de vous le dire je ne
sais pas ce que sont les ventes de janis
joplin aujourd'hui ce que je sais c'est
qu'elle est elle est dans un imaginaire
elle est dans un imaginaire collectif
international je pense et que son
personnage et puis son son talent de
chanteuse
c'est inouï denise ho pin musicalement
c'est pas rien voilà je crois qu'elle
est toujours là mais je ne suis
incapable de vous dire ce que sont ses
ventes de disques actuels
ce qui est certain c'est que on est
capable d'identifier savoie savoie très
rock et très puissante on était capable
de les identifier immédiatement ça
s'appelle donc love me please c'est une
histoire de janis joplin par nicolas
finez christopher et de greffe
merci nicolas finez ses sorties chez
marras bull
[Musique]
et nous voilà avec grand palladium un
groupe formé de kevin moelle
abba gaucher et vincent d'auvergne à ma
droite
vous sortez votre premier album éponyme
et vous serez en concert le 3 octobre
trois baudets vous n'êtes pas très janis
joplin j'ai l'impression que vous êtes
plutôt beatles à l' influence si
quelqu'un ou du moins si un groupe a eu
de l'affluence sur vous c'est les
beatles
ouais c'est un des groupes il y en avait
plusieurs inserts des gouttes sur lequel
on s'est retrouvé en particulier sur la
combinaison des voix ça a été un petit
peu le la surprise quand on a commencé à
travailler ensemble c'est de voir que
les voix se mélangent et super bien et
où là en tout cas que ça se mélange et
bien est le premier exemple qui nous est
venue en tête et quel exemple c'est
celui des beatles janis joplin vous
l'écoutez vous l'aimez ou pas du tout je
pense que janis joplin mais c'est un peu
ce que vous disiez avec votre invité
c'est nous c'est un peu la bande son du
de des années lycée années fac
tout le monde a écouté janis joplin et
donc c'est des références qui sont
certainement ancré en nous après là
c'est vrai que je ne peux pas dire que
j'écoute d'albums ont personnellement de
l'album de janis joplin par exemple en
sauvant alors on va on va vous entendre
dans un premier extrait c'est la chanson
j'aime mais on va voir que les beatles
médias se sont penchés sur votre berceau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quand u2
quand tu souris
[Musique]
et
m
oui
c'est
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dimanche
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà voilà un clip que vous avez
réalisés pendant le confinement je crois
c'est ça que vous avez fait vous même je
trouve que c'est formidable mais dites
moi y'en a pas de vous deux qui est qui
affirmiez au chru de brest tous les deux
en fait tous les deux et par le
confinement je croyais que vous
applaudissez tous les soirs parce que
vous étiez censés bossé comme des
dingues
en fait nous étions en train de faire
votre clip tranquille oui c'est de trois
heures doit occuper dans la journée donc
comme on pouvait plus sortir la porte
pour aller au travail ça allait bien
qu'on s'occupe
mais c'est également au chru de brest
qu'est mort mon grand ami christophe il
avait été transféré la barre et il est
mort alors est-ce qu'il est mort du duc
au vide ou pas on continue de l'ignorer
mais comment peut-on répondre encore en
tout cas et un la bad d'insuffisances
respiratoires ce qui était
particulièrement triste
comment vous l'avez vu vécu cette
période
quand même historiques notamment pour
des infirmiers c'est c'est eh c'était
très étrange d'être en même temps au
coeur de l'actualité
et puis ben nous on avait comme projet à
ce moment là de sortir l'album de
commencer la tournée qui était derrière
il y avait une bizarrerie dans cette
période je peux contrôler et une basse
et ça ça devait être quelque chose
d'assez incroyable pour nous parce qu
enfin l'album sortait que tout avait été
organisé pour que ce soit là maintenant
c'est à dire fin mars à la base et d'un
seul coup ça s'est transformé en quelque
chose d'assez bas ils perdent quand même
été assez catastrophique pour le monde
entier
donc c'est pas du tout ce qu'on
s'attendait à vivre en 2020 quoi ça a
été très surprenant et c'est pas fini
autre clip également fait maison puisque
vous faites pour vos clips vous même
emilie on en écoute tout de suite un
extrait
il ne reste plus rien dès la fin juin
qu'un verre posé dans un coin
[Musique]
il ne reste plus rien
juste au dessin
passez sur moi
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
où j'ai chanté pour toi
du cinéma
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais là
reste lui
et ça
[Musique]
sur d
et
que ces mômes
tu dansais sur
d'histoire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le bas
[Musique]
alors là y'a pas que les beatles on peut
reconnaître éventuellement un peu
saimone et garfunkel là aussi une
question d'harmonisation vocal quand
vous êtes rencontrés parce que ça fait à
peu près cinq ans que ça dure je crois
grand palladium
quand vous êtes rencontrés vous a dit
tiens si on chantait des chansons de nos
grands-parents où c'est arrivé comme ça
c'est vos voix vous y pouvait rien d'un
masque en 67 68
il faisait pas des chansons des années
10 en fait on a on a commencé à répéter
ensemble faire des boeufs ensemble et on
a eu ce trouvé qu'on avait une référence
commune
on a fait une reprise mais pour ces
milieux débuts de david bowie starman et
est en fait ce 10 mai lille c'est cool
quand on chante ensemble ils se trouvent
après que les références finalement
c'est les gens qui nous ont dit m et ça
ça nous fait penser à ça nous fait
penser à des trucs ou n'avait pas
tellement pensé à la base à ces modes
garfunkel ou à deux groupes comme ça
qu'on vient de nancy a pardonné et des
concerts assez vite et le fait de
vouloir aller vite sur scène juste avec
nos guitares et nous voit ça à donner
une teinte foule d'oiseaux folk qui est
qui est très très fréquentes dans les
années 60-70 qui une période qu'on adore
forcément on va pas dire linverse mais
ça va orienter beaucoup les choses au
niveau du style vous êtes rencontrés
dans les bars de bresse qui sortent
assez célèbre brest c'est une ville qui
a produit d'autres musiciens goût
miossec yann tiersen
c'est comme en bresse quelle affluence
ça sur deux chanteurs que d'être né et
de vivre encore à brest alors moi je
suis pas mais à brest je suis mais j'y
suis depuis suffisamment longtemps pour
être brestois en fait je pense qu'il ya
quand même une atmosphère très
particulière c'est miossec qui on parle
très bien qui parle vraiment de bresse
comme une espèce de bulle ceni vraiment
tout à fait la bretagne ennemis tout à
fait la france est quelque chose de très
très hétéroclite au niveau des cultures
et finalement ils gagnent culture
brestoise on recevra l'on sait c'est la
pointe du finistère un département qui
mérite bien son nom puisque c'est là que
la terre fini c'est l'extrémité de
l'europe
c'est pas rien bref tu as à apprendre du
pouce de marins que deux musiciens
d'ailleurs
oui sûrement puisque pour s'échapper de
la ville tout un côté où il faut aller
sur l'eau peut-être que le fait
qu'effectivement ce soit une ville qui
soit un petit peu éloigné de tout ça
change ça change des choses je sais pas
quoi exactement mais il ya passage on
passe pas en reste on y vient et je ne
saurais pas expliquer exactement ce qui
est ce que la partie que cette ville
mais en tout cas on la sent vraiment en
nous par contre ça elle est totalement
leur histoire jusqu'au bout je pense
pour les artistes ce serait plus facile
si on si on tournait en bateau parce
qu'en fait effectivement si on retourne
en voiture faut déjà sortir de bretagne
c'est à dire 4 300 kilomètres pour
commencer à tourner en france ces
inconvénients ski techniques non des
chaouis limite les choses alors je les
dis vous serez le 3 octobre ou trois
baudets peut-être qui voulons pas dit
mais les trois baudets c'est plutôt un
endroit on reçoit des chansonniers des
choses comme ça que dès que des
chanteurs et enfin il paraît qu'on y
fait aussi des concerts est ce que ce
que vous êtes sûr que le concert aura
lieu c'est dans pas très longtemps là
ils vont pas l'interdire d'ici là alors
c'est parti
c'est le 6 octobre ah pardon c'est moi
qui ai mal lu j'espère qu'il sera pas
interdite et ils ont verra bien tout ce
qu'on est en train de faire là on le
fait avec ce fameux point
d'interrogation et il n'est pas question
d'arrêter de faire des choses et prévoir
des choses maintenant si on doit
l'annuler et on fera ce qu'il faut mais
on part du principe que tout va bien se
passer et que ceux concernant un dieu
c'est un super notre boule de cristal
mais que ça va bien se passer
voilà il cotait je veux je vous le
souhaite
l'album s'intitule grand palladium il
porte le même nom que le groupe et c'est
donc le 6 octobre ne nous trompons pas
ou trois baudets je vous remercie tous
les deux
et nicolas finez s'il est encore là
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous au prochain numéro
c'est lui nicolas
[Musique]